I want to just read something really
quick from so you want to talk about
race do not force people of color into
discussions of race I'm doing that right
now
I'm just trying to amplify Amber's voice
thank you actually she is a hero in this
moment she's doing incredible things
she's dropping an EP soon which I we are
gonna talk about at the end or whatever
you want she started this incredible
hashtag that said we have a lot of
fuckin listeners so I get to do this
people of color live with racism each
and every day with no say over when and
how it impacts their lives it's painful
and exhausting when people of color have
the rare luxury to choose to not engage
in additional dialogue about race do not
deny them that even if this discussion
is really important to you you never
have a right to demand it so I was very
trepidatious of asking you because I am
sure you're tired I'm sure you have a
lot on your plate and so I just want to
thank you for being here I'm also a very
big fan and in case you didn't notice I
put on so much makeup I don't know if
I'm trying to fuck you I don't know what
I'm doing here but I've put on lip line
I appreciate it I looked and I said oh
this got blue eyeliner on with the blue
shirt and this phone like you look good
you look good art teacher from Santa Fe
I'd like an oh hi indigo a blanket Dyer
I don't know what I'm just she's in a
midlife crisis is what she's in so I'm
sorry I really went for it I got rings I
mean I put I'm pushing it depress you so
I just want to say thank you I've been
talking to a lot of friends you know who
are like
stop asking us how we are that's mate
you're making it about you that's not
your service for the day that's not your
action for the day by the way what do
you what a mind right back great never
know how I'm doing its if you know I
think it's it's just time out for people
to act like they're just now realizing
that racism is here mm-hmm and I think
the exhaustion comes from racism being
created by white people and black people
now having to find the solution for it
that's right it's um it's it's kind of
insensitive for you to want me to sit
down and it's black splain see you what
daily you know life for me is you'll
never understand it what we need you to
do is check your racist family members I
don't want to know about your racist
uncle or your racist grandmother or your
races on and how you don't agree with
what they you know what it is that they
say you don't get points for that also
you don't get points that you don't get
points for not agreeing you don't get
points for marching you don't get points
for tweeting something out you don't get
points for instagramming where it's all
of our responsibility and I and I just
want people to understand that like you
know I had to even check myself I'm like
I'm out here fighting for equality for
black people but I haven't been fighting
for equality for trans people I haven't
been really you know putting my name out
there as an ally for the LGBTQ community
and when a lot of my friends did white
friends did reach out to me a lot of
them are in the LGBTQ community and I
and I in turn apologize to them cuz I
said you know I I want to be an ally and
I want everybody to live a life where
they feel safe and intersectionality
does exist there are black trans people
mm-hmm there are black gay people there
are black bisexual people you know and
all of that if black lives matter all
black lives have to matter
and all lives we already know all lives
matter you know but they're they're ours
me without show Yeah right seriously
there's that there's just different
different degrees of struggle and it's
not about putting one struggle against
another it's the fact that we all
struggle and we all have the ability to
to in that struggle hmm and you know I
think you know my friend you know Phoebe
Robinson who's been on the show I was
texting with her today she gave me
permission to share this she said
it's such a mess I wish white people
would stop centering themselves in this
moment and it's just it's white guilt
mmm that's that's that's what it is and
where do you fall on white guilt because
me my producer was just talking about
this like you should have a little you
know it at least you're feeling
something you know I don't think any
emotion is useless yeah yeah just use it
to drive yourself to learn something to
educate yourself to read a fucking book
to let there our resources available you
yeah I gave them at the end of last
podcast I'll give them at the end of
this one you do not need to ask your
black friends to educate you on racism
they are not your teacher and you don't
get to get free labor from them we did
that for a while this country did that
for a while
built this country made a bunch of
people very wealthy much white labor
yeah we don't need to now ask them for
their free emotional and intellectual or
or as my nieces history book says field
workers you don't get credit you don't
get points moral points for asking your
black friends a bunch of questions and
forcing them to educate you yeah that's
not I mean I don't want anyone to ever
feel like you can't talk to your black
friends about stuff but come with
information hmm like oh I read I
actually was having a conversation with
court court Overstreet who was on the
show with me and he said that he read
the book
why I won't why won't be explaining
racism to my white friends anymore
and he said it opened up his eyes a lot
and we were able to have a different
conversation yes because we we're now
understanding systemic racism
institutionalized like we now understand
from a certain point like he was like I
took the I kind of took the blinders off
mm-hmm as opposed to someone that's like
so what's going on like I don't get it
yeah like how how are you getting
through every day like what is that
what's this black lives matter thing
like it's just okay bitch go go go go
get me in information as black scooter
who is who is more resourceful than
Google Angelou who wrote write fragility
said we make it miserable for people of
color to talk about racist patterns in
their experience because our feelings
take over and make us defensive I've
done that when I was younger you talk
about in you like well I'm not I don't I
mean but I don't do that it's like we're
not we're not talking about a racist
person we're talking about a racist
system yeah right yeah and I think we we
were kind of talking about it before I
think a lot of way people think of a
racist as like it has to be a white hood
and burning across and that's a racist
we're talking about racists systems yeah
when you say racism people automatically
think action mm-hmm they think um they
say and words yeah they think action but
what I want everyone to understand is
when we say racists where we are talking
about the system and what we're saying
is you benefit from that system and that
system was built to oppress black people
and people of color which are two
different things I'm gonna be stupid
Nancy Pelosi how come Oh
can we talk about that
we don't have to but I'd love to think
about it whoa the black clock is set her
ah they said them up I was like yo the
black hawk is told them to do that
can I play a video from a woman oh no
did it go away
there was a video that I wanted to play
about it what this is the Democratic
Party wearing the Kinte cloth of these
of the Ashanti tribe Oh too lazy to make
this kind of quick video response but
today something happened and I thought
it's actually important to note that I
get in front of my camera and make a
short video to explain something short
enough for for me to post on Twitter I
was just looking online today like most
of you and what did I see a bunch of
Democrat politicians kneeling down of
which I have nothing to say about that
because I am NOT an American however
they were all having around their necks
this colorful fabric which I'm sure they
put around their necks as some kind of
mark or show of unity or solidarity with
black people so in other words they are
putting forward the cantine material or
this colorful fabric they had around
their necks as they're some kind of
locating sign or symbol to show that
they are not racist and they are
together with black people excuse me get
Democrats in your tokenism
you didn't wait to find out that this
thing that you're hanging around your
neck is not just some African uniform
it's actually to contain material Teddy
Long's to the Canadian people yeah
mainly the Ashanti trying yes excuse me
Democrats don't treat Africans like
we're children these fabrics and these
ain't no colorful things that we have
within our culture and tradition they
all means some things worse I know you
look at something you say all Africans
you're so cute
in all your colorful dresses well some
of those dresses and patterns and colors
and fabrics actually do mean something
because it was some of them belonged to
ancient shrines and made something to
them so why are you using it as your own
show of non racism or you're unsure of
virtue
why are you using the contain material
to signal your virtue
stop it we are not children Africans are
not children and leave our tradition and
our culture to us and if you don't know
much about it ask somebody I'm sure
there would there be something else you
could have done to show your your Sunday
diary to in black people instead of
taking the content material and making a
little show of it well well and I also
looked up the meaning of each color they
were predominantly yellow someone should
have googled this but yellow actually
means wealth could someone have googled
what the colors mean before you put on
your costume I'm going to say that all
of this was August orchestrated by God
to let us know that that was the
bullshit
which we already knew which we already
knew and the Black Caucus
actually showed up with those and told
them to wear them in solidarity which
was a complete setup either somebody was
being funny or if somebody was
completely ignorant sabotaging yeah or
they were just completely ignorant but I
think it's important because you know I
don't talk about politics a lot and I
just don't find it helpful and I think
when we slam Trump we kind of help him
sometimes yeah you know I think a lot of
people don't realize that but I think
it's important to in Robin talks about
this she said everything I've learned
about white fragility is from liberal
progressives you know Democrats get it
wrong too yeah yeah and I think it's
important realize this isn't a Democrat
Republican thing Democrats screw up and
have blind spots and do dumb shit yeah
this this kind of stuff is Malcolm X
once said I don't believe in progression
hmm in the black movement because
you we have as a whole in our government
have to recognize that racism systemic
racism the structures that were built
we're not built for black people so we
don't even there's no such thing as
progression until that happened right in
total changes until until our
legislation actually realizes and that
the system that you built doesn't
benefit black people which is why we're
calling to defund the police which is
why we're calling you know to prosecute
killer cops and the narrative that is
put on that it's it's it's very it seems
like a radical thing yes defunding the
police seems very radical to people but
it's actually not and I can and I can
prove it please because in rich
neighborhoods white neighborhoods
well there's black people there too but
but in richer neighborhoods like your
Beverly Hills or your Bill Ayers
you don't have police sitting out on
every single corner people aren't really
robbing the grocery stores or robbing
their neighbors none of that is
happening because there's wealth there
so if we take the money the three
billion dollars that you want to give
these police who are killing our people
and put them in the neighborhoods and
and fund get the homeless people jobs
yeah that are stealing because that
nobody is ever stealing anything because
they just want to just like Kimberly
Jones's point she was like don't look at
the fact that people are looting look at
the figure out why they're looting why
we are in this country and people feel
the need to jump through broken windows
to get a pair of shoes why are we in
that situation in the first place
because that money isn't being put to
use how it should be result programs
mental health programs yes isn't about
no police officers defund the police
does I get why people just go to like
have no police officers this is just me
chaos you know the idea is that it goes
to affordable housing possibly
reparations yeah thing that but that is
but see that is reparation yes because
we built this country and the first time
that black
people did kind of not kind of but they
did built their own wealth black Wall
Street yeah you know it was a bunch of
groups of white people got really upset
that they were flourishing and they came
and killed and burnt that shit down I
have cried so much hmm
I've cried so much in the last three
weeks some are happy tears because I do
see people starting to wake up
mmm but I hate that it had to take eight
different camera angles from for joy
George Floyd to lose his life I hate
that minutes a 10-minute video and I
hate that and lost his losses life after
eight and I hate that it takes people to
see black pain for them to make it real
I hate that we have been silenced and
told oh you're just the black angry
woman oh you're a scary black man oh you
I hate it because I know so many
beautiful things about our culture and
we got our own shit too we're not left
to deal with it in our own community
without outside influences judging it
but we got our own shit that we have to
deal with but on top of that we have to
fight on the outside you know when we
were when we were brought here
we were stripped of our identity I don't
know I don't know you know I know that
my roots are a Cameroonian and Ghanaian
but I don't know what tribe I was from I
don't know what my family there I don't
know our traditions I don't know our I
would like my original language can you
imagine being put on a boat for months
you're laying in other people's throw-up
in feces and dead bodies laying on a
boat you get to a country and you're
just you don't speak the language and
you're being yelled and stream at to
work to build and you have no clue what
is going on all you know is when you
don't do what they tell you to do they
beat you
you learn to do what they tell you to do
and to be quiet and that has been going
through our culture we have learned in
our culture do what they tell you to do
policing was was founded in Slade
caching to protect white neighborhoods
in their property which was to catch the
slaves and bring them back you know
these are all things that people can
just google and research and understand
there's never been a moment in history
where a president has stood up and said
we need to reconcile what was done to
the two black people Australia did it
mm-hmm
for the aboriginals that are there but
our country has it and so having the
understanding that you will always as a
white person or a white passing person
benefit from systemic racism from racism
from from white supremacy you benefit
from it even if you're not involved you
benefit from it and until you are
actively trying to not benefit from it
to push against it to speak up for your
black you know black and brown brothers
and sisters people of color that that
suffer from epping handle police it's
it's just not going to get better and I
do understand you know comfort the
comfort in knowing I'm going to have to
purposely put myself in an uncomfortable
position to for progress to happen
mm-hmm I'm going to have to be okay with
everybody telling a racist joke in this
environment which is a microaggression
and my black friend is there and they
don't feel like they have their own
agency to speak up you have a crack
whole lot the licensed professional I
have to be honest on this show we
obviously talked a lot about therapy we
talked a lot about edifying yourself we
talked a lot about taking care of
yourself your feelings your resentments
your fears that though
and I realize a lot that not everyone
has time to drive to a therapist not
everyone I mean they're so expensive the
reason I love better help so much is
because you get to do it in your own
home on your computer you can log into
your account anytime send a message to
your counselor I've said this before my
big problem with going to therapy is by
the time I get there I'm already pissed
off I'm stressed out takes 45 minutes to
drive there I'm there for an hour it
takes it's like three hours door-to-door
now I have an anger management issue
that I didn't have before I went to a
therapist more money yes it's great
because better help is not a crisis line
it's not self-help it's professional
counseling so you don't you can do it
you don't have to fill your worst to
call in you can call them whenever you
want for a check-in it's therapy over
what else I mean the service when I was
20 and dating narcissists it's available
worldwide this service committed to
facilitating great therapeutic matches
so they make it easy and free to change
counselors if needed
see that's amazing because I always have
a hard time also we should do better
help service dogs cuz Mona is
auditioning right now hi Moni what are
you doing yeah you always have a hard
time figuring out if the counsel you
have is right for you and this way
they're helping you figure that out for
you and it's more affordable than
traditional offline counseling and
financial aid is available as well hold
on Mona sorry my dog is really wanting
to jump on the table but I have been
therapy so I'm not apologetic I am not
ashamed it is what it is and I'm an
acceptance you know I just think it's so
important so many of these podcasts are
talking about therapy and how to improve
your life and improve your relationships
improve your self-esteem and self-worth
with no actual solution that's what
better help does it's more affordable
than traditional offline counseling and
financial aid is available
better help once you to start living a
happier life today visit better help
calm slash Whitney that's better help h
ELP and join over 500,000 people taking
charge of their mental health with the
help of experienced professionals
special offer for good for you listeners
get 10% off your first month and better
help calm / Whitney I'm you know me I
like to golf book here stop being crazy
there's no excuse anymore okay I'm
talking to some of my girlfriends
talking some of my guy friends and they
are just like
same problems for 15 years pull it
together break the cycle get better help
it's enough
you can't call people crazy anymore Oh
what do I say
nuts get help better health alright what
have I been texting you lately Benton
that I need smoothies vitamin vitamins
vitamins and I get so I don't know I get
so overwhelmed
I mean I've talked about the podcast I
do not feed myself well I'm not good at
it you know like I'll pick one thing to
eat for like a month
yeah you love a cracker in a smear and I
just I'm so bad at like just having a
variety of foods thank God for what
daily harvest I'm obsessed with these
things because I'm so good I want to be
really healthy but I also have
absolutely no patience yeah those are
easy and it's already in a cup but a
little straw hole and everything so it's
basically it cuz I'm like ah I'll go to
the store and I'll get freaking
blueberries no my gosh shoot I forgot
the raspberries yeah like bent it can
you stuffing it in banana and then I'm
like oh shoot now the raspberries are so
spoiled because I like I can never get
like a rhythm down of getting a bunch of
different yeah you can also leave your
fruit and encounter a lot I know I'm
saying bad at it like I feel like these
were made for me well these are they're
fresh clean food they're already yeah
you just put them you imma for those of
you listening I'm holding one up that
was in my freezer just now it's all
pre-made already in the cup yeah you
just add whatever like liquid you want
water or like the go-gurt of 2020 yeah
and then you blend it up and you put it
back in here and you go with it never
uses preservatives no added sugar no
artificial ingredients they work
directly with farms and they freeze
organic fruits and vegetables at peak
ripeness
to lock in nutrients and taste I
actually learned about these like a
couple months ago my friend Leslie
Grossman was using them on her Instagram
and I was like what is that because all
it's just so easy this my favorite one
is cacao and avocado yes my favorite one
I'm not I don't cut me off I have energy
a lot to say I have nutrients now
because I have a daily harvest in my
bloodstream
cacao coconut avocado zucchini pumpkin
seed dates pea protein like I feel like
if I either
I don't have to stress the rest of the
day because I feel like when I'm not
eating just like one of these every
morning I have to do math the rest today
I'm like okay I had two grapes and then
I had a lima bean like two weeks ago and
like I had a zucchini chip today so I
feel like I've got enough iron like I'm
always doing math and wondering and then
I need to take like a fish oil pill to
fix that like I'm always stressing out
about whether I've had too much or too
little and then it takes up so much real
estate in my brain if I just have one of
these every morning I feel like a box
checked have one of these have my prozac
I'm set for the day and they are great I
love the carrot and cinnamon smoothie
but to be clear they don't just have
smoothies guys they also have soups
harvest bowls flat breads and more they
have a lot of stuff if you want to snack
throughout the day on something healthy
they have these as well and like I said
the cool they never use preserve like I
said they never use preserve like I said
can you not the audience is listening
they don't you don't need to they're not
ignoring you they never use
preservatives added sugar or artificial
ingredients they work directly with the
farms and they freeze organic fruits and
vegetables at peak ripeness I like this
one oats raspberry blueberry dragon
fruit and mulberry this is another one I
like I look at my skin I look good I
look great I look amazing I think it's
because I'm having all these vitamins
that is probably true they aren't
delicious organic raspberries organic
dragon fruit yeah it's bringing out my
inner dragon maybe and they're also
committed to minimizing their
environmental impact they're in the
process of transitioning to a hundred
percent compostable recyclable packaging
and are over fifty percent of the way
there already you know what I did with
this the other night I put some on ice
cream no she's done yelling thing no
what no what are you gonna say I'm an
outlaw native I get cream but I like it
cuz you can kind of do what you want you
can put you can fill it up with like
milk or soy milk or coconut milk or you
can have it cold or you can put like hot
water in it you can like young your own
thing you can be your own bang and
they've made it really easy for you to
do it for kids I don't have children but
I imagine this is a really good thing to
send them to school with and then
they're gonna make all their friends
jealous they're gonna blend it up in
their blender at school know some of
these you don't need a blender for why
are you so jealous of me I'm just
letting you know the carven mom and
interpro moko good for you to get $25
off your first box
that's promo code good for you for $25
off your first box at daily harvest comm
daily harvest dot-com delicious truly
nutritious wonderful I being in the
business were in mm-hm and I've heard a
lot of white people say you know well
know everyone's know none of my black
co-workers complain they're fine they
can't they fuckin can't in so you want
to talk about race she talks about how
she always had to be overly polite at
work dress everyday like it's a job
interview laugh off racist jokes try to
make my voice quieter was told my hair
was too ethnic yep so just I think we
have you know and in Hollywood I was
talking about this the other day is we
do see so many successful black people
we do a lot of people follow you know
Kevin Hartz and Michael B Jordan and you
know Lupita and we're like okay we're
good yeah oh it's good we're done right
so this video which no one can unsee has
I think really shooken up that ignorant
of like oh I thought everything was fine
look at all these rich but it's but I'm
sure of you really if they ever wanted
to really talk about yeah and I think
know what I'm saying and this is part of
what you're doing with this yeah part of
what I'm doing with this hashtag is I
have started hashtag haul on mutiny and
it's a black woman founded and led
movement and the intent of it is to end
black silence in the entertainment
industry the whole power structure
accountable for suppressing black
experiences and to confront
microaggressions with courage we have a
lot of things that we're planning with
it but this first phase of it is really
to just get people to tell their stories
it is not a lynch mob nope that's not
that's not the point
witch-hunt it's not a witch-hunt it's
not a I'm calling you out
it literally bore out of Samantha where
who is the one that
spoke out against Lea Michele from what
happened with her on the show and I saw
a black woman getting attacked because
she was selling her truth and I was like
oh hell naw no I got a I have to do
something I have to say something and
being I'm just a funny person I'm funny
and I'm silly and so of course I like
put my little gifts up in response
tricking I put my gifts up in response
because I've kind of done they've done
the work to get passing over that and I
never want my life in my story to be
entangled or my career to be entangled
in somebody else's stuff you know other
people you don't want that to be your
Google search yeah that's that comes up
it's just not it's it's just not
important to me what was important to me
was the stories that I was getting from
specifically black women who felt
comfortable with me to tell their
stories about you know being on set and
certain things that they felt like they
felt like they had no say in what they
did with their hair mm-hmm they felt
like they couldn't you know call out the
little micro aggressions that would
happen that people don't think it's
racism hmm you know putting on a song
and saying the n-word in front of a
black person because you you know you
won't you know that that's gonna start
an argument and they don't want you know
to you know it's all of those those
those little things and so I wanted to
create a space for these black men and
women in the entertainment industry to
be able to tell their stories and
collect them yeah kind of stuff that
people are posting is every white person
should read it black people know what's
going on this is homework for white
people you vet Nicole Brown I remember
being on set when fans had come visit
one was celebrating a birthday I
exuberantly said happy birthday a white
male castmate said the word is birthday
not birthday why can't you enunciate I
castmember put their entire hand in my
hair and practically scratched my scalp
I had just met this cast member about a
week earlier when I made my frustration
clear in the moment and even wrote an
email to him later his response was oh
okay should I talk about one of my
theater directors who refused to learn
my name and called me it is now the time
I mean these are I was so upset that a
brother said to me instead of having a
conversation with the employees
expressing my concern a valid concern as
the only black female student in the
class while others rehearsed modern
materials I could only be assigned to
play a slave in a satire christine
social is her handle continued I'm sick
and tired more needs to be done in this
industry we are more than just playing
slaves we're more than just playing the
sidekick to the white woman we are leads
we are humans black women are more than
that we are capable of so much more so
there you know I think again per your
point of we think of racism as
cross-burning saying the n-word
you know attacking a black person
allowing this stuff to happen around us
and not using our privilege to stop it
from happening and to protect the person
who doesn't want to push it you know I
talk to you a lot of my black friends
were like eh I never spoke up because
I'm I'm just so afraid of coming off
angry of coming off belligerent coming
off difficult and I don't wanna lose my
job I've been literally told that oh you
know it's just unfortunate but you know
the white girls just their they're not
disposable the black you know black and
people of color they're they're more
disposable that's just that the world
that we live in in Hollywood I remember
one of my first auditions big auditions
for a show I walked in and this was the
producer call
and I did whatever and got all the
laughs and it was really good and I felt
really confident and I walked out and
now mind you the role that I was going
for I was the only black one the other
the others were white and when I walked
out they called me back in and I can
hear the producers arguing and I walked
back in and they go okay so we we need
you to you know give it a little more
spice we need you to you know give it
and the the the one white man there's a
producer he's an actor too and I cannot
I cannot remember his name or his face
but I know that he was an actor
and he was just like this is ridiculous
he was pissed and he spoke up he was
like this is ridiculous I'm not sitting
in this room for this and he walked out
and you know I was like I think I was
like 13 or 14 years old so adding child
your child yeah I didn't really
understand what that was about but they
were like you know like kind of urban
like you know how the black girls like
give me a little neck and give me a
little and I'm just I do remember
thinking well did they ask all the white
girls I were out there to do that or is
it just you know me and so I just did it
hmm because I you know I wanted the job
I was told by a hair person my natural
hair is really thick and curly and I was
told by the head of hair that I said oh
for the for the gallery shoot I'm gonna
wear you know my own hair and they told
me it would just be easier for us if you
just wear it war week this the gallery
shoot is like for the Billboard for all
the stuff you see any tea the big
important one instead of finding someone
at the biggest fight when I was in the
middle of that created a show you know
you get
in the middle of the contracts and stuff
and what will be allocated to whom they
were okay with the producer credit that
I wanted you know the creator credit all
of that stuff they're okay with but when
it came down to hair it was like the
fight of the century yep I've been on
shows where a black cast member shows up
and the makeup and hair people don't do
black makeup or hair it's a thing a lot
of hair and makeup people do not know
how to do black hair and makeup any any
what's more fucking white centric than
that and it's and it's I was like so
this is the thing you guys want to fight
me on not the percentages or the points
that I'm worried about the budget for
your hair getting your hair prettier my
hair person or getting approval of the
hair person that's you guys getting
tests and you guys picking a couple of
people and me being able to have
approval because it's not fair that I
would have to do my own makeup it's not
fair that I will have to do my own own
hair no you're getting paid for that and
for you to not understand why that is
important and how I present myself or
for you to not care mm-hmm I mean I
worked on something where there was a
rain machine and there was black girls
like I'm not going on to the Wraiths
machine like why not that's real she had
to be quote difficult
she's holding things up because people
didn't take the time to understand
didn't watch Chris Rock's documentary
whatever it was to educate themselves
about it and then she had you know it
were kind of at a point where in white
feminism when you set a bound you're
asked for something you're a bad bitch
you're a boss right we're not at that
place with black woman women where they
feel like they can advocate for
themselves without feeling like they're
angry well that's why black women most
black women don't subscribe to feminism
yeah
oh the women's March first women's March
I learned that the hard way went out of
the women's March not one black woman
not I was like wait what's happening one
it was like we put up the black the
black woman that symbol like we're going
shit I went I called a girlfriend of
mine and he was black I was like hey
where are you she was like ah white
women jumped the line is what she you go
first and we will sit we will sit and
then I went to the second woman's March
and there were five black women there
and they were holding signs that said
white women are wide Trump is president
[Laughter]
copy that
yeah it's um you know right now you know
there's a lot of like I said I'm I'm
more of a person that like I'm a healer
like I want I want unity but before we
can get that we have to know what we're
unifying we have to understand what is
going on and I was trying to find okay
where do I fall on the spectrum of
activism hmm I am a nerd I like to read
I like knowing facts and figures and you
know percentages and okay I love to be a
I love being able to explain things to
people I want it to be a teacher I'm a
singer my voice oh we know the guy oh we
know the gift that the gift that God
gave me his heels and settles and I know
that about about myself I was a funeral
singer I had a funeral singing career
okay
because if we're like your voice is so
healing I'm like okay so I I had to
figure out where I fell on the spectrum
of activism and for me why I say like
celebrity activism really isn't for me
she just yeah you tweeted that because I
don't care about the optics of it right
it does it a lot of it feel performative
and cloud chasing can I ask you a dumb
question when does it not feel
performative
I mean like okay that's helpful I'm I
can't he I can only say for myself oh
yeah
one black person's answer doesn't
represent yeah yeah I can only say for
myself like first of all all skin folk
and kinfolk so just because a black
person is doing it doesn't mean it is
right in this scenario are no Hurston
yes so you need to know that but for me
personally it's a it's the intention
behind why I'm doing it and everything
that I do I talk to myself and I'm like
are we doing this for optics or is our
heart in the right place
who is this going to help how is this
going to help them what is going to be
the resolution everything that I do I
want it to be resolution based which is
why we had that six hours
strategy meeting yesterday for unmute me
because there has to be a solution it
can't be you know if you put if you're
gonna put out this frustrating and fiery
energy then we have to be able to hone
it and and put it somewhere constructive
and that is that is ultimately the goal
I think it gets performative when you
just show up to take a picture and go
home I think again I was happening up
quite a bit yes yeah and I think it gets
performative when you shoot a music
video in front of in a March where it
should have been a vigil and in about
Brianna Taylor who's killed who's
killers are still not over they're still
walking around here free I think it gets
and that's just my opinion
mmm-hmm I think he just gets it gets
performative when there's no risk when
you're not when you're not afraid of
losing something when you're afraid of
losing something so you choose to be on
the safer side of things and just while
we're talking about it if that pissed
you off to hear that about Brianna
Taylor called Louisville Mayor Greg
Fischer at 502 five
and for 200 three and demand the to fire
the officers who murdered Brianna Taylor
you can call the Attorney General Daniel
Cameron at 502 prosecute 6 9 3 5 300 and
demand he charged the officers who
murdered Brianna Taylor another number
yep I got them all day when this is out
there's really no excuse to Parisi for
you guys you can send an email if you
want to send an email instead attorney
general at AG KY dot gov listen they all
know me by now I have time I will sit
and read I'll read I don't care if you
guys got that thing off the hook I'm
gonna get through eventually does it
dumb question I'm asking them not scared
time for white people to bare not dumb
question yourself if you're wrong
they're not dumb cray I'm white I'm
fragile but I gotta get over making this
about my fragility is it frustrating to
have to be such a dumb question to have
to deal with this every day and also on
top of that have to be an activist this
is a white vibrant want to sex at it
this is white people's problem this is
our problem to solve the victims are now
having to solve the problem of the
perpetrator it's it's painful mm-hmm
it's frustrating but it's it's more
painful because it's willful ignorance
at this point I don't know if you've
ever had a situation where you were
trying to get somebody's attention for a
really really long time like hey married
man hello and it's yes hey hi
casting directors HBO yeah my dad dad's
approval yeah oh no don't make me
laughing my dad my mom fine wait once it
just becomes it's it's that feeling of
okay now everybody wants to listen and
that's great because it's popular so
there was a there was a time where black
lives matter was a radical which I'm not
I am not affiliated with the
organization I want to make that clear
my opinions are my own but there was a
time where hashtag black lives matter or
saying black lives matter was radical
yeah now it's popular because as as in
the zeitgeist as well as we've seen with
with black culture over time a lot of
things happen with black culture first
that are demonized until until someone
white comes along and Columbus's that
shit and then it's popular so there's
black lives matter was once radical now
it's not right at all anymore everybody
saying black lives matter it's the
popular thing to do it's popular to you
know go down to the March and have your
signs and all this kind of stuff it's
very popular to do it we have to move
past now black lives matter and move
into the real work this isn't a trend
it's not a trend it is not a moment it's
a movement movement means we have to be
moving forward Herman I train it that
means every day we have to be figuring
out what am I going to do today to fight
white supremacy what am I going to do
today to to amplify the voices of those
that know what the fuck they're talking
about what am I going to do today to
teach myself I you know there's so many
white people that are like I'm talking
to that are like I don't know what to
and I don't know if I should post or
shouldn't post I'm like what is the
Confucius repost someone that needs more
followers repost people that do know
what they're talking about and they
won't have to put in your own words you
don't know you don't know you should not
be I'm a gun izing over this caption
people asked me to proofread their
captions I just retweet Britney PAC Nick
Cunningham just retweet other people my
girl no Britney I was like love her so
much you're my mentor I don't care I
don't care I don't care yeah I'm
following you I annoyed her cuz her shit
i annoy her every day I love Britney
there's actually something really cool
going on share the mic to share the mic
where white women are lending their
Instagram to black women mm-hmm to
amplify their voices and to be able to
talk about things that are going letting
them take over their whole yeah and and
and honestly it's it's it's all all in
an effort to even the playing field you
know that dumbass tweet that Terry Crews
put out about black supremacy but Rosie
does not exist shut the fuck up that
dumbass tweet is what we're what we're
trying to be it's about equity and
equality right that's what we're
fighting for
we're not fighting to be a head or above
white people we're just fighting to the
point where we can all just understand
that we're people mm-hmm and we all
bleed the same blood David or yellow
just said it's so concisely and clearly
we just want a piece of the pie we
helped make it's nice and and it's and
I'm and because I mean if it was even
some of this stuff with systemic racism
all that was ingrained in me you know
I fell I fell on the the site of what
black on black crime until we you know
get together they're gonna they're not
gonna respect us until we start
respecting one another no that's
bullshit crime is a result of not having
the same opportunities in the same
education the same after school programs
and mental health resources it's like
that's not addressing the root of the no
not addressing when your only option in
life is crime you're going to you're
going to
and black-on-black crime doesn't exist
just like white-on-white crime doesn't
exist and asia non-asian crime doesn't
exist it the numbers that people are
seeing are the stats because of
proximity we are in black neighborhoods
therefore usually when it's a violent
act
it is against another black person if
you are in a white neighborhood
predominantly white neighborhood usually
if there's violence it's gonna be
against another white person so that is
not an excuse who's close behind
it's literally who's close by like in
that it's and I felt so dumb when I
realized that cuz I was like that's kind
of common sense
this is a mapping that's common sense
ya know that's what I'm using common
sense I'm gonna use that from now on
there was something I read that was
really I hate the word powerful but when
there were the protests going on which
I'm gonna call bullshit on the media
right now the because websites and news
media that sounded weirdly
all-righty are so about clicks and so
about absolutely use they're only
covering the drama
yeah the negativity these these protests
for the most part although some blind
spots and some not reading the room like
the majority of these have not they're
just playing one clip about someone
breaking a window you know yeah and
that's it so it's like projecting that
to everybody that's ever these are riots
like it's just not true but one of the
protests would kind of turn into a march
they made very sure to go into bel-air
there was a huge conversation about the
coming to bel-air we need to board up
all the acts why they were afraid and
the purpose of that was to make rich
white people uncomfortable so that they
knew what it was like on some level a
modicum of what it was like to be black
every day
oh you're uncomfortable for four hours
yeah black people live like this every
single day right
so that was intentional and I think
people were kind of missing the points
of that yeah it wasn't to go it wasn't
to go down and destroy anything no one
wants your found that's that that's not
but also
understanding like what I said before
when people we're looking at the symptom
when we really need to be paying
attention to the problem of the pill the
symptom is yes people still the symptom
is yes there is violence in our
neighborhoods the symptom is yes some
people are not getting proper education
in Ingle at Englewood high school one of
my friends sons was going to go to high
school they share books and they can't
take the books home and they Xerox pages
to read and these are teachers taking
money out of their own pockets to do
this so you want to tell me
defunding doesn't exist you defunded
education in these impoverished
neighborhoods time after time hmm
they're getting less and less mm-hmm
they're the parts are abysmal we're kids
when I was growing up we're beautiful
yeah I grew up in Compton California and
I I had a better view of going out and
being a kid even though that there there
was violence and gang violence and all
of that and we can even get deeper into
that but I'm not gonna even I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna even go there
because we will literally be here for
hours but I think people's main takeaway
is check your priveledge check your
priveledge understand that you have it
and know that we just want you to
recognize it it doesn't mean that we
hate white people no no it doesn't mean
that you know we think white people are
bad and you know what I'm saying but we
but we need you to understand that you
also are operating in the system and
benefiting from it and it might be
subconscious mm-hmm like if like I think
you know it's important to read this
tweet from Duane Reade REE D white
supremecy won't die until white people
see it as a white issue they need to
solve rather than a black issue they
need to empathize with hmm so there's a
little bit of this sort of white Savior
like I'm so sad about this I'm talking a
lot of people that are so upset about
it's like no one needs you to be up they
need you to do something yeah just like
you being sad it you're just making this
about you
and the way Robyn D'Angelo defines white
fragility as the inability of white
people to tolerate racial stress this
leads white people to weaponize their
hurt feelings and being indignant and
defensive when confronted with Rachel
Rachel Rachel racial inequality and
injustice sorry I get so nervous reading
these quotes wait a minute are we are we
are we now gonna call racism Rachel
Rachel inequality
Rachel's upset rachel injustice he feels
attacked rachel has posted the black box
on her Twitter she has posted a selfie
of herself at black guys matter in
Europe oh no Rachel cannot handle these
Rachel injustice racial discrimination
is about Rachel go oh my god that is so
funny what I see white facility I think
of a girl named I was like Rachel by the
way reading MLK quotes letter from a
Birmingham jail the other day with David
Oh yellow odd and I kept stuttering I
kept stuttering just I was so nervous
reading an MLA and okay in front of him
and I just kept fucking it and then as I
was reading it I saw two lines down that
the word Negro was coming up you can
hear me stutter I'm like I've known that
and I looked at him like can I say it
was awful it was awful but fine fuck it
I'm happy to be Rachel today windy I
would you to not be so nervous and
scared
this white fragility thing I get what
she's talking about cuz I think there's
this perfectionism I want to be perfect
anti-racist I don't want to come I don't
want to make any mistakes we have to
make mistakes right now we have to be
able to buck up we have to be able to go
you know
I think I handled that wrong I'm sorry
yeah like I you know it's interesting
because I was thinking about your
hashtag and having worked in writers
rooms and run TV shows and look I I was
an EP on Roseanne you know it's been a
tricky road before the tweet before the
tweet I left before the tweet but I
found myself when I you know black
people that worked at the shows I was on
I found myself like overly compensating
to try to make sure they were
comfortable and represented to a point
tour was almost like patronizing yeah
and then oh and I was actually making
them work harder I didn't even realize
so it's like we're in a writers room and
I'd so badly wanted to make sure they
felt heard and that they that you know
I'd be like what do you think what do
you think honestly what's forcing them
to talk more the names of what you know
what I mean it's like yeah you know and
just good intentions that's how we're
talking about yeah no one's like I think
when people hear white privilege when
they hear white fragility they they
think you have bad intention so that
were talking about we're talking about
your conditioning we're time of your
program we're talking about subconscious
racial bias and just being a zombie
going to the world benefiting and not
even necessarily knowing you're
benefiting you know 16 19 please listen
to that podcast it really helps oh so
good so good you understand the way we
are still haunted by slavery the way
black people are still haunted by going
to the doctor by going out and just all
of the traumas the ancestral trauma that
has been inherited and health conditions
that have been inherited the constant
generalized anxiety and fear and PTSD of
like can I go bird-watching today
without Rachel calling the police on me
the daily traumas you know and oh my god
and so Rachel it's just a very important
to realize like no one's saying you're I
think white people are so afraid of
being called a bad but we associate we
go
you have white fragility you have white
privilege you're a bad person you
haven't had it hard everyone thinks
they've had it hard everyone's had
adversity in their life because the
first thing that usually when you talk
about white privilege is they'll say I'm
not rich that's not what solvers think
that's not what we're doing
no but you probably the merit in your
head right yeah you probably do have the
ability to go into a store and not be
followed around or you can wear the
feeling outside that up or the feeling
of going to a store and having to make
sure that you greet the person and make
eye contact with the security because
you don't want them to think that you're
coming in here to steal that is a big
thing for me
I was I was yelled at by by someone
going into a store with my friends you
guys have to come in here one by one and
I'm like why cuz I had no intention in
stealing and you know so I'm totally
like you know those little those those
little that wasn't even that was blatant
racism but like even the little
microaggressions like the touching the
hair and all like all of that and you
know for white people it's not about you
being a good person or a bad person it's
about you being a person it's seeing
another person and being able and like
please stop with the I don't see color
shit that's bullshit
I'm something eridium everybody sees
color you have to not attach judgment to
that color and how you react to that
person you should be able to see the
nine very very black I don't care if
they're ghetto I don't care if their
vernacular isn't like yours I don't care
you know if they got red braids or
whatever we have to erase these
judgments and these these stereotypes of
when we see black people that's what you
need to work on it is it is lazy to to
not see color I think but I think white
people truly think they nail it when
they say that I'm colorblind done
handled like huh are you actually good
what like what are you
is the dress golden fluid gamer plane
was blue the dress is blue I don't know
I don't see color I don't see ID I just
saw it in black and white it was blue
damn it can I read you something Nicki
Minaj said oh no sure what happened no
don't pick me in a corner Whitney what
are you by the way what did she say it
was just about you know we I've been
seeing a lot on Instagram no save barbs
no shade don't come for money no shade
at all we love Nicki just just what let
me start with this being a lot on social
media of a quote that just says love
black people like you love black culture
oh yeah you've been seeing that a lot
yeah we've also been saying that a lot
and why or what what is that
help for the people that don't
understand what that means what does it
mean white people make a lot of money
off black culture
look at you music industry mm-hmm
would you like to chime in on that no no
if I chime in on that I'm gonna have to
name names and I have promised that I
wouldn't get in too much trouble think
about it you want
Nicki says come on you can't want the
good without the bad if you want to
enjoy our culture and our lifestyle bond
with us dance with us have fun with us
to work with us rap with us then you
should also want to know what affects us
what's bothering us what we feel is
unfair to us you shouldn't not want to
know that yeah since we've sat down I've
really stopped myself from crying
just so you know don't I mean talking
about obviously it's really try at it I
know it by the way don't it don't if you
don't want to play I be guarding what it
is that you just said about the industry
this touches on it a little bit
but I'm playing this in tribute to jazz
and who she was brilliant writer
brilliant writer but she talked her shit
and it was amazing and this is what she
said that's the music industry as a oh I
really have to say I appreciate with
Justin Bieber posted mm-hmm
I think that he really meant what he
said I also do not but but you know if
you guys didn't know Whitney she films
us in a bunker so I have no service on
my phone we're literally in a bunker let
me get you all know we're not in a
bunker no I forgot to get you online
hold on I'm gonna do that right now
yep you're on BAM you're welcome let's
Bank you active anti-racism today
no not how it works okay so this is what
Justin I I appreciate appreciate it what
Justin Bieber what jesse has an affair I
don't know if he needs me he has a
hundred in 38 million like he's good
Justin how do you suppose named jus does
he have a duck is his thing yeah okay I
think that has something that I'm
inspired by black culture oh yeah and a
fitted off black culture my style how I
sing dance perform and my fashion have
all been influenced and inspired by
black culture wow I am committed to
using my platform from this day forward
to learn to speak up about racial
injustice and systemic oppression and to
identify ways to be part of much needed
change and then he went on to like you
know put some people post on people that
he posted uh sure
that's been
you know that he admired yeah people are
waking up and and and and coat and it
being cool is a part of people waking up
and being more comfortable and speaking
out about it and this is something in
the industry
that myself and my manager talk about a
lot because I'm coming out with an EP
finally coming out with original music
and when does that come out I can't okay
I mean there was gonna be a rollout but
then all of this thing happened and I
was like it's completely tone-deaf
that's just way completely tone-deaf for
me to put anything out right now and so
we've kind of had to regroup and figure
it out but one thing that we do talk
about is how hard it is as a black and a
black artist to be an R&B artist that
writes and sings what white artists do
and if people don't understand how the
industry works as far as radio you have
to you have to pick a job genre mm-hmm
before your music comes out because that
is going to determine which charts
you're on and the reason that people
usually pick like urban black people
pick urban is because they won't put you
on the pop charts they just won't
they'll put you know white people that
sing close to army music or legitimate
aren't legitimate army music that are
written by black artists and that are
produced by black producers but if it's
a black girl then it's not gonna make it
to the pop charts is that like I mean I
thought this was just straight-up racist
but when they didn't put little nas X on
the country chart yes it's like it's
it's the same or when they they got mad
when Beyonce saying country on the CMAs
she's saying daddy's little girl she's
saying that song from lemonade which was
a country song and she's she's from
Texas
like she sings she grew up in country
music too but the CMAs posted her on
their page during the awards
people went nuts because of it and they
had to take the tweet down no people
were upset country music is ours you
know so it's it's in the it's in the
music industry also there are millions
of stories about it there there are
artists that wanted to be artists and
ended up becoming writers because the
labels were like well we love the song
we don't know if we can sell you with it
but can we give it say you know X Y Z
white girl white boy and Shania Twain
singer yeah
Shania Twain right that's literally you
know happens and then black people end
up becoming once again the producers of
the culture but not the face of it and
these are just these are just facts like
I feel like when I feel like as a black
person when we talk about this things
like this the first thing people want to
say uh we get it you're black you're
oppressed like we get it but no it's not
it's beyond that I live in a system
where I can't fully be myself and speak
my truth every day and like or have
about truth and that's you know that's
the main reason I started on mutiny I
want black people to be able to feel
like they have a place where they're
they can air their grievances and it'll
be that energy will be taken and
something constructive will happen with
it and I'm going to encourage black
actors producers anyone in the
entertainment space I'm going to
encourage you to please continue telling
your story start right now that is the
first phase of what we're doing hashtag
on mutiny and white all of your it's
it's it's so you know it pisses me off
that you know black people have to do
more work to now now I had to live
through this I got traumatized by this I
not to tweet about it like it's it's you
know the onus is now why people to learn
about that so they can then see it and
go oh yeah he just said some that racist
joke but everyone's laughing at like I
need to do something about that
mm I've dealt with that too you know a
racist joke said in front of me by
somebody that was very powerful that
could in my career that actually reached
out to me because there's afraid now
this episode is brought to you by Hass
when he did you know that ask is the
that's the one I mean not that I just
brought in here from my bathroom because
I actually use it did you know that it's
used more than any other film in TV so I
do you think I have it I everybody's
obsessed with my hair I've become a hair
icon in the last couple months and I
totally think it's because of this dry
shampoo it's amazing the charcoal want
this one that one is gorgeous the she
can I don't know for a lot of cursing is
good it is the crap purified dry shampoo
okay this one I use buff this is a
little trick I learned I do it when my
hair is wet and then I dry it and then
for the rest of the week I do the
thickening dry shampoo shampooing set a
fig you abyss you you I can't speak
French but there's some French on the
bottle I've started wearing this and I'm
gonna tell you something
not only have I become a iconic sex
symbol but yeah you know tell us more
because of how voluminous and messy my
just like bad head like like did she
just have sex or like did she just come
out of a tornado or wind tunnel like I
don't know what it is but I just want to
marry she in a hair metal man who knew
and my lover that I have taken he is
always like what perfume is that and I'm
like boy
it is hask also you have really dark
hair and these never leave that white
residue which is key the most important
a lot of these dry shampoos you do it
and then you go out and people look look
at you like you're crazy and you come
home and you realize it looks like you
just like threw a bunch of baby powder
on your head yeah they're amazing yeah
I've been using the shampoo and
condition it has biotin in it I'm
actually using it for you guys not
watching that's just hearing that's done
I haven't turned into is that arsenite
colors safe free of sulfates parabens
artificial colors no gluten it's
formulated to meet the needs of your
specific hair type
so cruelty free we love it we love to
see it and because their ingredient
inspired fragrances they smell
incredible that is I'm truly smelling
like stop me on the street people smell
it through their face masks there's like
ma'am what I've been asked what my
perfume was and it is actually just ask
ask tea tree oil and rosemary
invigorating collection and here's the
here's the bad news
using hats does not make you more
literate or more able to read no happy
as you can tell but if I my stuttering
the teacher oh and rosemary collect in
the green tree oh that's our new one
yeah their new one it's really good - I
know but you stuttered so I just want to
different use a lot of products like we
do on our hair yeah yeah we'll get you
right I like it makes it thicker just
like and then you can kind of style it
without doing anything do you know to
mean it starts to become just very
malleable quit washing your hands we
took I did it kind of looks amazing like
I can sort of do this like sideswipe
vibe great and Aniston did that thing
when she sort of twisted it and it just
I don't know yeah it's a very body fall
very body audio yeah Albuquerque cruelty
free already said that has tea tree oil
and rosemary invigorating collection and
other house products are available on
amazon.com as well as online in-store
Ulta Walmart Walgreens Target and CVS we
are excited to announce that hask is now
hosting this is awesome weekly giveaways
for our listeners where you can win $100
prize pack that includes shampoos
conditioners leave-in sprays dry
shampoos and more for your chance to win
I want this are we allowed to enter
enter the giveaway at husk UT comm /
Whitney and look out by the way look how
big the bottles are yeah they let some
high soul that's why I hate about dry
shampoo you use it like twice and it's
done for your chance to win enter the
giveaway at has beauty calm slash
Whitney the hask Beauty sorry that's
hask beauty.com / Whitney and we thank
them for sponsoring this podcast and for
making a product I like to use that
makes me so sensual and sexual and
attractive to men there was a quote in
Queen and slim Lena way throaty and he
said she was just talking the girl was
talking to him the character about black
excellence
he said why do black people have to be
excellent excellent all the time how
come we just can't be like why do we
have to like strive because we really do
I mean like I went so hard and
everything that I did my parents made it
very known to me you're going to have to
overachieve
hmm to to seem like you're on the same
you know playing field so you're gonna
have to go beyond you're gonna have to
take more classes you're gonna have to
learn opera you're going to have to
learn be classically trained and be able
to sing gospel and be able to sing pop
and be able to sing R&B you're gonna
have to practice more you know you're
gonna have to read and be intelligent
and be you know well-spoken and I
remember my first my first interview
you're not to be well-spoken unless they
tell you to be more black yes unless
they tell you to be more but in which
case go be that means move your neck
that means that black people don't speak
like this which we do we've always
spoken like this in mouth I remember my
first interview that I did after the
interview the lady goes he puts her hand
on my shoulder I hate this bitch to this
day I see her all the time on TV like
she put her hand on my shoulder and she
goes wow you are incredibly well-spoken
so eloquent and I go thanks why are you
so surprised she goes no no no no no no
it's not like that I was just you know I
said you were surprised because I'm
black
oh no that's not what I meant
had a run-in with her again on another
on another different show we were doing
our interview something was happening in
the background they were still setting
up the camera and I was looking behind
she was like oh can you look into camera
and I thought I heard somebody say I
said okay I thought I heard somebody say
my name and I turned away round again
and she literally took her hands and
turned my face to camera and I I am
really from Compton like and
I don't know if people know this but all
black people have an invisible bubble
and you Rico Rico Rico V we have always
socially just it is very disrespectful
for you to step into my bubble but to
touch me when I tell you that I my fist
I my hands were bleeding because my
nails were digging so hard into my hands
cuz I wanted to knock this bitch out did
you honestly just touch my face are you
out of your mind same bitch and didn't
even remember me from the first
interview and from the interaction that
we had because I tried to remind her of
it so she either didn't remember as she
played ignorant or was ignorant or was
ignorant but that the fact that you felt
comfortable brazen enough yeah to put
your hands on my face and turn my head
around oh you have lost your mind you
lost your mind
but there's some positive things that
are happening I yeah I don't I don't
want to all view like this can I ask him
we can always cut it how do you feel
about the band Lady Antebellum changing
their name to Lady a they did not take
into account the associations that way
down this world referring to the period
of history before the Civil War which
includes slavery oh so they heard about
the movie that's coming out oh is that
it
Antebellum yeah what's name is that you
know um Janelle Monae oh I've seen
playing the lead antebellum I mean it
makes me feel more comfortable
optics III mean if it makes me feel like
like I said like gestures are cool but
like I don't I don't really mind can I
just you a question how do you feel
about when celebrities post the amount
they donated or that they donated is it
setting a good example
or is it obnoxious and Bragi I I think
it's a little bit of both mm-hmm I think
it's like
Hey look I did something but I also
think that it encourages others to give
I think so - I'm very torn on it I don't
know the answer and I did something on
the pack I swear I made fun of
celebrities that think a post about
donating is a donation like when rich
celebrities ask people without money to
donate from their mansions they're like
just donate to this cause like how much
did you donate just to be able I think
it's ok if you're if you're saying hey
like I said I actually was in DC and was
walking around cuz I loved I just love
DC I love I'm from there do you really
love walking yeah see and there was this
a ice cream shop Southwest soda pop shop
nice and it's black own love and I was
just kind of walking around in that
particular area I think it was I want to
say it was like the fish market yeah
yeah yeah so they were over there and
I'm just like kind of like walking
around and this black girl comes up to
me she goes hi can I get a picture with
you and I said oh yeah so we take a
picture and she goes well this is you
know me my my family's a ice cream shop
and I said alright cool I said I'll get
some ice cream so I went and got ice
cream and they were like shiny came to
me I was like no I want to support black
businesses area so I like bought my ice
cream I was hungry and and I bought my
ice cream and like I you know recorded
it and kind of put it on Instagram was
like hey guys I got my ice cream so the
girl reached out to me that I met there
and she was like it's a long shot but
you know we have a GoFundMe because
we're trying to stay afloat and because
of coronavirus blah blah blah blah blah
so I was like okay how do i I want to
let people know about their GoFundMe and
I'm going to donate but how do I do that
without making it making it about me
yeah so basically I said hey guys I'm
going to donate a hundred dollars and
every one that matches my $100 I'm gonna
send you a private message in your DM
that you can save you know and that they
I think they raised like five thousand
extra dollars or something like that
stuff with soda pop shop awesome and
and and I felt like that was a way to do
it to where people knew that I was
actually giving yeah and it's also a way
of sending the message like hey you can
do this - mm-hmm a hundred dollars like
you know stop actually gave more than
that but yeah but I didn't want to weird
to me shame around money you know we
have so much shame and you know for me
I've just sort of been in this position
where I'm just like do I donate the
proceeds so I feel like do I let people
know I donated the amount
hmm I I posted the amount and then I
took it down and then I really like I
just was like fuck I just want to set an
example that I'm walking the walk
without trying to be sanctimonious or
bragging or performative and like you
guys we have to talk to Whitney about
her white guilt we have to like figure
out we also just talk about my eyeliner
brand because it's getting in my image
your eyes are the waterings and you sat
down and cried that was a motion now
it's the fucking makeup because I think
you made me cry and now it's all going
down my face and I look like fucking
Marilyn Manson no it doesn't it's not
going down your face at all it's not
it's not going down your face you keep
doing this though so now you have this
is now you have winged eyeliner blue
wings such a desperate look you have a
blue wing keep doing this well because
my makeup is wax I use wax makeup yeah I
wish I figure out wood that way special
effects makeup that I got out of movie
that they use it on a movie so it's wax
so you just can move it around okay so I
really wanted its wax based though this
is for like horror movies like that's
cool yeah because the water-based drives
me out and the oil it kind of makes you
shiny
I like well that's my thing that's my
brand okay always she's never not shiny
shiny am i so shiny right now you don't
bleed the thing stuff back you mean
coordinates Whitney not that fragile is
my forehead look like an oil spill it
was like a low table
okay what do we do we do we not shine I
don't know I look like a jellyfish let's
be honest oh my goodness you were
talking about some good things that are
happening yeah okay so la mayor Garcetti
cutting a hundred to 150 million from
the LAPD budget to be reinvested in
communities of color sis good news it's
a gesture okay
I'm not going to say more please okay
more please I think this is I think that
because there's little moments my sister
is about to die cuz we had like do you
wanna come she has she hasn't do this
literally heard me going off about this
man so oh you like yeah doing the
electric slide okay
something else that's extremely funny my
friend Kent have you ever met Kendrick
Sam say no just a fan yo does it found
you he's someone that you would want
just a fan he's completely unfiltered
yeah we are doing the very trepidatious
about like sliding into his di because
I'm just like he's bit I see what he's
doing every day let me let him like
sleep eight hours and um I'll connect
you guys but this is a so there's a
guide form on bumble I've been looking
for him ever so fine so this guy I
complexity on Instagram he takes stuff
that people says and he turns them into
like songs so we were doing the electric
slide in front of the the mayor's
mansion yeah and this is what we were
doing it to my dad got so mad cuz
[Music]
he's not he's not so yeah my dad is like
fuck the patriarchy burn it all down but
he does not like me cursing it's the
most bizarre thing ever that is the only
thing he was mad about he was like well
if you get arrested you know call me but
cursing in public does that have to do
with like having to maintain an image
yeah I think so my mom my mom hates it
too mm-hmm but it's cool
I've had a potty mouth my whole entire
life mm-hmm cursey makes me feel really
good did your parents ever give you a
talk of like I mean we you mentioned a
little bit before your mom you have to
be twice as good if a cop or you have to
like was ever a talk of like this is how
you have to conduct yourself in public
you know I played the video last week of
a black teenager he was saying all the
things you know don't wear a wife beater
make sure you always have a receipt when
you walk out of stores don't put your
hoodie up don't let your pants like all
the things where you told as a as a girl
not so much because that is usually a
talk that they have with black boys but
it was it's in the comments that your
parents make that you download oh okay
people do get followed around in stores
I remember my mom walks through the
grocery store around the corner one day
and we lived in a predominantly white
neighborhood at this point and she left
her wallet she only had her checkbook so
she wrote a check for our groceries that
day
the guy was just chirping about the
check like he didn't even put it in he
was like oh I would have to call the
bank you know he was being like he
didn't want meanwhile I could have been
like I forgot my wallet can I just paid
him next week when I sure yeah yeah so
it's those little that you saw you know
those little stories and things that you
kind of download as a black girl because
you know black girls experience is a
little different than black boys
experience but one thing that is this
that is the same is we have to grow up
really fast we don't we don't get
childhoods like others
childhoods we have to understand things
understand racism and understand how we
have to move through the world
differently and and you get it you you
see it you know they're little black
kids being arrested yeah I just watched
a video last night of a little I think
he was like literally he's talking keeps
12 he was 12 years old and he's
literally talking and I'm like he sounds
like Mickey Mouse how are you arresting
someone that sounds like Mickey Mouse he
literally was like get off my back man
like you know this little voice and they
put a bag over his head saying well he
was spitting and then he was like no I
wasn't and they were like well we don't
want to risk it if he spits so they have
him arrested in the middle of on the
concrete with a bag over his head and
there's this you know over-sexualization
of black women and children hmm their
children the whole thing that happened
with Mike Brown and Trayvon Martin I'm
like you guys are acting like this was a
grown man he was a child
Mike Brown may have stolen cigarettes or
whatever it is that they said that he
stole from the place why they stopped
him he's a kid he's he was a kid it's
never a listen dumb kid don't sell weed
yeah
don't don't walk around you're 16 don't
walk around it's never it's it's it's
never that and so you want to talk about
race
she talks about how we should challenge
the language that stereotypes black and
brown kids how often have you heard
people talk of thugs hoodlums
gangbangers and known almost immediately
they were talking about black and brown
youth our children are criminalized in
casual conversation yeah school was
tough going from a predominantly black
school to a white school walking home
having a bit goat throwing at me and
being called a nigger a big gulp Oh a
big gulp oh wow big slushee thrown at me
being caught over here when that
happened 16 was 16 years old when that
happened countless stories of being
without that white school countless
stories there was a picture that we said
we were bothered by of a black hand
holding cotton with a sat with the Sun
rising in the background in our office
in the office we were like take this
shit down like take this shit down what
is I'm not gonna laugh but that is just
beyond it's funny it is funny like it's
a cartoon offensive it's yeah it's
stupid but us bringing it bringing it up
was yeah shoofly do you now that you're
famous and successful do you ever have
to deal with the ethical dilemma or
moral dilemma of like what parts you are
willing to play and what parts feel like
I really want a job but like this is
just not absolutely you have to all the
time and you have the added pressure now
of having to be a role model and not
contributing to these images that you
know we see if the black best friend or
the sassy black or whatever a stereotype
yeah I've kind of I've kind of moved
beyond that cuz it's not even just me
being a black woman I'm a plus-sized
black woman also and
- you know we talk about
intersectionality that's a whole other
issue in in in Hollywood you know you
think black women don't get leaves or
Asian women don't get leads or you know
plus-size women black plus-size women
don't get leads you may see a Melissa
McCarthy but you're not gonna see or you
know Queen Latifah because she's gotten
her respect in the game and but she
rarely ever see women that look like me
that you know play leads but I am very
specific with my agent about stuff that
I want to go out for I'm like listen I
don't want to just be the Jiminy Cricket
character who keeps the white person
from doing something crazy in the movie
I call it the Jiminy Cricket effect when
the black person is like the moral
always conscious yep yep yep yep yep you
go to for advice
let's do everybody well the guy you go
down to the basketball court where
they're playing basketball outdoors and
to ask hey I need some advice and the
wise sage advice yeah Jiminy Cricket
character the whole you know it's a it
it's a lot and I think black people are
unfolding it there's some some black
people that are also taking their
blinders off because it hurts it hurts
it hurts to recognize that all you were
disrespected by that person oh you were
assaulted by that person you were made
if that wasn't just a joke that was a
microaggression
like we have learned like just like our
ancestors taught our great-grandparents
or grandparents how to just be quiet
suck it up and in you know shrink and
then we got a little more liberation
and now it's like just be satisfied with
the fact that you're not you know
segregated that you don't have
segregated restaurants that you don't
bah bah bah bah and now it's - it's
another era where we're not just gonna
be satisfied we want what we want what
we came for
well we were brought over here for we
want we want to be paid we want
reconciliation we want you to help us
build community Kimberly Jonz we don't
own anything we don't own anything I
mean I just like burst into tears when I
it's the kind of thing that as a white
person you just don't ever have to think
about that we don't own anything we
can't build wealth you don't on a
hamster wheel have agency we do not if
even if you have the money to build the
wealth like people are trying to buy
back the neighborhood you still got to
go through City Council to get permits
you still have to deal with the police
showing up because it's a crowd of black
people and that's a threat you know
there it's it's it's it's a it's hard
moving forward two steps and then being
pushed back five and then having to push
even harder to get you know further and
and I don't I don't want white people to
see black people as victims hmm that's
not what it is this is just our reality
we are very resilient people we just
never had the opportunity to really
build communities we have sub
communities there's New York culture
there's Florida culture there's
California culture there's Texas culture
but there is no one unified voice all
across America of black people that are
saying you know we don't have that one
leader we don't have that one voice that
we speak to that speaks for us we just
don't have that and that was done on
purpose divide and conquer that that was
that was that was done on purpose
stripped them of their identity
than their identity don't let them don't
let them ever come together with you
what's happening now no alliances which
is what's happening now and I'm really
trying to be that person all these
different organizations and all these
different protests and all these
different you know can we all just come
together agree yeah because it's this is
this is too much you have to eight can't
wait now you got the two can't wait yeah
I think you have defund the police and
you got abolished police which I am an
abolitionist I do believe in abolishing
police and I do believe in abolishing
prisons and I think it's important to
say you know when people get overwhelmed
by that and freaked out by that we
talked about this last week about the
cahoots program in Eugene Oregon which
was an experiment in sending out mental
health professionals to de-escalate the
situation it's just taking a new
approach yeah to this sending out mental
health professionals instead of police
with guns first first responders that's
right
funding there's there are first
responders in in every community they
don't fund them they fund the police we
don't need if someone that has you know
autism is having an episode or is
bipolar is having an episode and child
or a child is getting a bag put over
their head and is stressed out and does
not have the tools yet yeah to manage
stress and fear I the the person that
shows up doesn't need to be a police
officer the person that shows up needs
to be someone that is trained to deal
with a mental health issue that knows
how to restrain without harming and
deescalate and and and nurses know how
to do that my friend Sheena she's the
she's really funny she's one of did the
really funny video that went viral of
telling people like don't bring y'all
assets to this hospital if you don't
have Kobe you know she was so fucking
fun it was so beautiful we became
friends over I surrender Rachel have a
splinter Karen is her mom
and she demands to speak to the manager
and she we I had a conversation that she
was like amber I have had hostile
patients all the time and not one time
has it been reported that they have a
mark or a bruise on them but I begged
pain cuz we learn but we have my finger
banging bands fix it but she's really
you know she was really helping me even
understand the separation in in the
hospital business how they put all the
black nurses on the lower floors without
all of the supplies and things that they
need and up on in the NICU with the
babies and like all of those the surgery
centers and all of that or all where all
the white nurses are so she said as far
as those numbers going up she said it's
nurses that are actually getting sick
black nurses and black workers that are
actually getting COFA and that's a big
reason why the numbers are going up also
because we have to work in this
environment she hasn't seen her son in
months she hasn't been able to hold her
son in months because she doesn't want
to risk you know him getting COBIT if
she does or anything you know she cuz
she works in that in an actual
environment so so it is very very
possible for it's very very possible for
there to be a world where police is not
the first response I'll start there
abolishing police scares people mm-hmm
we're gonna say defund they don't know
why it scares them but it does do
they're like well who would protect us
and black people are like killing us
yeah they don't don't protect us they
protect y'all like it they are there to
protect us from you that is that is the
whole way that it was set up get that
through your head they're not here to
protect us they're here to control us mm
you know they're not we're not even seen
as
as lives at this point if you can put if
that same video came out and it was a
dog why people would be pissed this is
correct so a friend of mine said I
didn't want to bring it up I didn't want
to bring it up but a friend of mine said
the other day I have black friends I
don't want to brag people people say it
like I mean people throw that I have
black friends like that is that that's
it you're like as if you donated in some
way or you get points for that
he said if white people just treated
black people half as well as they treat
their dogs medical care healthy food
invite they sleep in the bed you know
that $300 car whatever if they just
treat us half as well as they treat
their dogs I mean actually Munda my
girls are spoiled
there's your dogs there's not homeless
white people it's um it's a doozy it's a
doozy they also think that black women
are just being dramatic when we talk
about our symptoms they're very much so
dismissed
not to mention plus-sized black women
when you go in if you are anything
bigger than like a 120 pounds 110 pounds
they're gonna tell you that your root
issue is your diet I bet that has
happened be the inherited ancestral
trauma that's my immune system and my
cortisol higher yeah like I'm like no
like when I was dealing with anxiety
really bad and I didn't know that my
symptoms were anxiety I was dismissed so
much by doctors I finally had to find a
doctor of color she's in an Indian woman
and she sat down and actually had a
conversation with me whereas another
doctor told me well I don't understand
what do you want me to do cuz I had a
migraine for seven weeks I don't
understand what what it is yeah I mean I
can give you these and these
anti-inflammatories but honestly the
headaches are probably coming from your
diet I was like well
I am vegan by the way I've had migraines
for 19 years no one ever said that okay
I'm vegan right I actually work out five
times a week and really love it I've
recently lost thirty pounds so I don't
think I don't really think the fat hmm
I really don't think that that's the
reason that I'm having migraines and
then then it was it was a mental health
issue and it had a lot to do with what
what was happening just like in the
world that's really what it was and so
yeah because it really is neuro
chemicals adrenaline cortisol that's
what migraines are from a lot of people
stress the stress of just being black
when my nervous system is triggered my
nervous system was it was on a thousand
like my heart was beating out of my
chest to the point where I kept going to
the ER cuz I thought I was having a
heart attack
and nothing was helping nothing will
calm me down nothing until I realized oh
you're depressed and you have anxiety so
then I found you know the help that I
needed and now I'm okay but I took me
going to multiple doctors telling me oh
it's just because you're fat before I
actually sat and talked to someone that
listened to me and that's that's the
issue I mean I I had a my mom had a
friend that died a year and a half ago
because she went to the emergency room
and she was having breathing issues and
she was like no I know that I have
asthma but this is different something
is different something's not right and
they completely dismissed her they gave
her a little breathing treatment and
told her to go home just use your
inhaler and she died as soon as she got
home because I I and I and I am in no
way like I know it's kind of like when I
was an actor and and we're like three
years in on Glee and people will be like
so are you excited I understand that as
an as an ER doctor
this is shit you deal with every all day
and you can't emotionally get involved
with it or you will be depleted when you
get home I understand I I understand
from that standpoint but you this is the
job you chose there's an angel there
you're going it's like I understand
where you're coming I forgive you
well because I tried you know I try to
be balanced in my in my thinking and and
see what a person where a person is
coming from yeah I always try to have
that balance so that I can respond in
the correct way so that the result is
what it should be so I do understand
that some people need grace and some
people need to because the fuck out and
and you have to be able to fit the
balance and way and be like
now I'm gonna cuss you out today like
that's that because this is this is just
you being an ass huh you know that's the
that's the difference
but yeah balance is important people
understanding just so like reiterate
some of the things that we said because
I wanted to be a teacher and this is
what teachers do just something just
something am I gonna be tested yes this
is you know just some bullet points
black people are not trying to as Terry
Crews said create big black supremacy
which does not exist I've never even
heard anyone utter those words like he
pulled that so far up from out his ass
like I I was like blacks up what is
black supremacy do not get these white
people scared thinking that we are
trying to achieve black supremacy that
is not what's happening your op message
please shut up please the tweet was
trying to find the tweet I stopped
following him after the oh yeah a couple
when you came out and you just decided
that you were going to make nobody sorry
he writes defeating white supremacy
without white people creates black
supremacy the quality is the truth we're
all in this together now
what was that somebody actually
corrected his suite and said to do me
and i retweeted it but it's like okay i
understand what you're saying about you
know defeating white supremacy without
white people it it's the war it's the
wording that was bothersome to me
because what you're what you're trying
to do is make it seem like we need to
beg massa
to defeat white citrons yo so BR else we
gonna rise too high can you end that's
not equal scroll up a little bit a
hundred and fifty thousand like
and you see and you know what I'm sayin
this is the shit and that's why I was
like I responded to this and I said
black people do not do this this is not
on message of what it's trying to be
accomplished I think it's important to
as I said the other day if black people
were gonna fix this themselves it would
be fixed white people need to get
involved white people need to solve this
problem but saying it's black supremacy
if like white people don't what so this
just doesn't make me sad some that's old
it's an old thing to say yeah oh god
like I've never I've literally never
heard black supremacy ever in my life
like I've never gone to any rally or any
council meeting or any town hall meeting
and anybody walk up and be like the goal
is black supremacy we are at a complete
deficit in that regard that is not
fucking gonna happen that's not so but
if you're saying we need our our eye
allies to be involved in order to fight
white supremacy because that is equality
waiter that I can tweet out I can agree
with I can agree with that but you
trying to make it seem like it's this
weird black people use your you're
making it she yeah you're making it a
fearful space you're making it seem like
it's a fearful thing to black we're
letting them come together that's not
that's not the message at all so I don't
know I don't know what that man is on I
all I know is when he came out during
the me to movement about balls getting
grabbed I was gonna say Venus or some
things I know baby is Whitney she's
gonna say his balls being grabbed black
women were the ones that had his back
black men were making fun of him and
black men were making fun of him like
you couldn't you big you could have in
black women we're literally like no it's
wrong to that is also wrong you know and
so for you to turn around and do what
you did to Gabrielle Union yes I'm
saying it it was wrong nobody asked you
mmm-hmm nobody asked you you did not
have to you literally could have helped
by just shutting the fuck up just
retweet her in solidarity that's why I
said in it doesn't matter what the risk
is for me in a Hollywood space right now
I'm not letting Samantha wear stand
alone in her experience that's that if
if we're gonna be united and what it is
that we say that girl was traumatized
that was her first TV job that was her
first TV job she still held trauma from
it
she said that's where it came from she
was like I wasn't even trying to be
malicious but to see somebody hop on a
movement and then knowing as a black
person you treated me that way and then
to see you try and say the opposite she
was like triggered and that not have
been able to say something when it
happened and and and literally couldn't
you know literally and that's why I said
that's why I'm starting a mutiny that is
the whole it is a it's black woman it's
black women black women started movement
led movement and our intention is to end
black silence our intention is to is to
let me look at my notes I know I was
like and I want to make sure that I'm
very clear I have a - I'm having my hair
no I'm gonna I'm gonna send you the new
ones that we have okay because we have a
more clear message but hashtag un mute
unmute in one Y which is does not mean
unmute New York it me
New York's louder not yes I put on
mutiny because when you just say it it
sounds like you're saying a mutiny
mm-hmm and that's what it is to to not
be silent is to start a mutiny in this
industry and it's a black woman funded
lead movement intended to end black
silence in the entertainment industry
hold power structural structures
accountable for suppressing black
experiences like Samantha's which people
were really trying to do and confront
microaggressions with
courage because microaggressions are
micro they're small and at five thousand
cuts and it's like am I gonna choose my
bout I have to choose my battles yes and
it seems like Annie creates an
environment where racism is comfortable
hmm because it's like I said racism has
evolved as we have evolved and that is
how it comes out so that's the point of
unmute me and I just want to be very
clear about that message it's not about
people it's not about a lynch mob it's
not about people coming out and just you
know being reckless with with the
messaging it's specifically right now in
this face everyone telling tell us our
store tell us your story
put it in the hashtag I know that it is
a safe space and what is going to be
done with your story is going to benefit
you at the end and it's going to hold
these networks accountable which they
should mm-hmm to be held accountable
Simon wrote I had a number of things
happen during a play I was in but one
thing was that the director would always
place me in the back of the theater cast
me as a maid during a song also had a
cast mate tell me during one run through
that my hair looked quote less crazy
than usual yep I write that one it's the
kind of thing where it's like what I'm
going to say that when I want to
complain now I'm the problem
now what are the ramifications of me
protecting myself and standing up for
myself now you're emotionally exhausted
you're having to do more work at work
because now you're going to be the
difficult one and then and networks
gonna see and that's what I said listen
I am very aware that what it is that I'm
doing is probably gonna get me
blackballed but what it is that are of
that is so fucked it is but but you know
what it's fine because I want to open up
a door for my niece tianni who tells me
she wants to be me she's in she's ten
nine
she ten yet she's nine yeah she's nice
she's nine years old and she's like
auntie I want to be you I I just she
she's my you know biggest fan and she
has been since she was like three when
she realized that I was on television
she's
does she have any concept of what's I
think that her mom is figuring out
figuring it out because she's already
experienced something at her school but
I feel like there's that there's also
that you want your kids that have the
freedom to be themselves but you want
them to be protected and it takes a
little bit of the innocence away when
you have to be honest about what the
world really is for a nine-year-old but
I do think that she understands cuz she
you know my sister had to FaceTime me so
she could see that I was okay and I had
to explain to her the reason the auntie
is protesting and the reason the auntie
is out here and showing her face is
because she wants to make a better world
for you because the world isn't good
enough for you right now so when you get
older it would be better cuz we may not
see what it is that we're trying to do
in our lifetime I'm perfectly okay for
that but I need us to leave some kind of
legacy so that they can continue on the
fight so that we can eventually get
there so when my niece goes out for
Hollywood parts and has auditions and
plays a lead to play the lead and you
know and is on you know a TV show or
whatever she knows that she's in a safe
environment because now is the norm for
racism to be bad it is a norm for
microaggressions to not be accepted in
front of anyone and I have a group of
black actor actresses actors that I've
spoken to about this that told their
stories like Ryan destiny and Vanessa
Morgan and Yvette Nicole Brown and like
I said Samantha ware and Robin thede
like I have all of these people that
have had thousands of stories and that
we've exchanged that are committing to
what it is that I'm trying to do so it's
gonna it's gonna happen because there
are power in numbers
yes and it's coming from a good place
it's not coming from a place of making
people feel bad but correction
correction isn't isn't always you know
coming from an evil space yeah
correction is good for you too yes yes
yes yes and I think the onus is on us to
not get defensive to not no one wants to
be right wrong know some people do want
to be racist but some people don't want
to be you you know you don't want to be
wrong and you're like I haven't been
mean to anyone it's not about what you
haven't done at this point and what your
intentions are as we said like you know
and I just want to be super open and
hopefully maybe settings able to go like
please crack me tella should have said
that fuck I'm so sorry like I'm sorry
just say I'm sorry when you fuck up you
know create a space where people feel
comfortable correcting you and don't get
to make it about your emotions and don't
make it about your ego and don't make it
about your I have a black friend and I
dated a black guy and whatever fucking
shit that I'm getting a lot of text
about right now
you know what I mean yeah and see
yourself when your ego comes out you
know I think when someone says you have
white privilege or someone says that
made me uncomfortable no one's saying
you're bad person unless you're being a
bad person like if it's like you said
well-intentioned and you're teachable in
this moment like receive that you know I
think that we're people that are posting
the black squares it's like they want to
get all the clout but they don't
actually want to receive feedback and I
think it's important that we allow
ourselves to like really be open to that
and it's so funny because even the black
out the black out tuesday thing was
co-opted how there were two black women
in the industry and cigars acharya and
it was first started to highlight black
businesses that's what the blackout
tuesday was supposed to be look and then
Brittany posted if you're black do not
don't go and don't eat all were like do
not post black lives matter under these
pose because if you do hashtag BLM its
drowning out all of the information and
the people that actually need to be
heard you're performative activism
you're trendy activism people just
silencing black places are today in
it got co-opted into something else and
I was like it wasn't even supposed to be
this black square shit part apart like
before the music industry girls got and
had ahead of it it was two other black
girls and it was a pause a pause in
Hollywood or something I forgot what the
specific hashtag was but a pause and
enters oh stop the show
hashtag saw a shadow and it was supposed
to be for us to take a moment and let
amplify talk about a black business that
you hate your eyes talk about something
like that like that's what it was
supposed to be about it was supposed to
be about you not posting about yourself
uh-huh and and and highlighting or your
boyfriend yes oh my god so many people
posting their black friend so many
people are posing their black Brandon so
obvious you're so obvious guys you're of
these follow Brandon Goodman as well
he's giving some etiquette tips here on
how to behave right now I'm just gonna
let you which is basically stop checking
in on your black friends you will notice
that checking in is in quotes which is
to signify that it's not a genuine check
that it's more of something that is from
your guilt and your shame of whatever
oppressive behavior you subjected that
black friend to especially if it's a
black friend that you're not in regular
communication with it's somebody that
you were like who are the black people
of my life and you might have noticed
you don't have any but there's that guy
that you used to talk to in high school
or that guy used to talk to I don't know
a couple years ago and now you're
checking in on them if you know that is
not you honey but it's not you if you
know that you're checking out checking
in a genuine way you know that you're a
black friend that you're in relationship
one appreciates that check in then honey
we're not talking about you but thermia
are we talking about
but some of y'all we talkin about cuz he
please stop checking in on your black
friends who you haven't spoken to in
months let alone here don't use us to
feel better or absolve yourself from
whatever oppressive behavior you may
have subjected us to in the past
do your work do better leave us out of
it yeah like general consensus that's
what you guys need to take away from it
not that you can't talk to your friends
about things that are happening now but
come with information I don't want to
teach you there are enough follow
Britney pod save the people hide save
the people so good Tara Brown follow her
like she'll let you know 1690 you know
what listen to 1619 we said last week we
posted a bunch of resources we'll do it
again this week
white fragility is sold out great news
on Amazon but there is still is an
audiobook so you have no excuses I'm
gonna ask a couple dumb questions
Madison do you want to take over do you
want take over come on come on in this
is my god baby and my assistant Madison
some dumb questions from people on
Instagram that I told you were coming a
lot of them are about Fe and The Wiz and
Glee and I'm gonna skip them all oh yeah
Bab white woman Amy Whitney you know
going in the right direction a little
bit kind of charming as a white male how
can I help black women Madison as a
white male how can can he help black
women
please stop telling us on tik-tok that
you
think we're beautiful I just love black
women they're so beautiful
she's a millennial but I'm actually not
you are among the oh you're Jin Zi yeah
she's got some real new shape um yeah
and start trying to touch my hair all
the time they it's the amount of white
win cuz I live in a predominantly white
city that come up to me especially when
my hair is like out oh my how do you do
that to your hair it is just so
beautiful yeah I don't really have an
explanation
you can stop exotic sizing black women
you can just hey treat them like white
women treat black women like you do
white women like just people maybe some
people maybe you humans
maybe I mean but if it's like if you
need specifics I don't have any you do
okay - that one yeah you cannot see what
my nails I love hearing that yeah notes
for me as a jimsy kind of thing about
notes like thoughts feedback things that
you're like ah which they had said that
which they brought that up
I wish Whitney was more knowledgeable
about that Oh Whitney are very
knowledgeable Thanks yeah just that take
white guilt and do something with it you
having your white guilt doesn't doesn't
help any like also don't do it I've seen
a lot of people doing enough to calm
your white guilt like you're doing
enough so where you're like okay today I
don't feel guilty like that's not what
we're asking we're asking for you to
make a move don't do just the bare
minimum so that you don't feel guilty
for the day but not enough to where you
made an impact that's that's the thing
about white goes what do you want to see
the next week what do you want to see in
the next month what do you want to see
in the next year in the next we
eeeek I want to see more movement and
unless gestures and the next month
I want our cuz I think they're voting on
July 6 or 4 this le budget I want to see
the denial of this la budget in the next
year I want to be pregnant and married I
want a baby and I want her to have a
somebody get me pregnant
thank you
any black white I don't care just
pregnant and well-endowed I went on a
date with the white guy and one of the
first things out of his mouth were was
also you know what did your mom do oh
you have my mom's in you know Terrier
decorators she's a minister she
synthetic planner and she's really good
and my dad oh you know your dad so that
kind of put a little bit of a stop to
that for me I said yeah yes I know my
father oh no that's that's not what I
meant
I just meant we were talking about your
mom and then you brought your dad into
it and I was like yeah okay and the date
continued because I do not reject free
food and told him to lose my number
meanwhile I didn't know Dean is a strong
term she's different
i I grew up with a lot of white boys I
would
honest I want a group in Thousand Oaks
okay so point zero one percent black so
that was really fun for me yeah can you
tell them the story do we have time for
her to tell the story of your
documentary of what it was like being
black as your senior project mm I am for
my senior project cuz a lot of schools
they make you do senior projects so my
teacher loved documentaries so we
watched blackfish and Super Size Me and
all kinds of documentaries the whole
year so she was like the second semester
we're gonna start working on our
documentaries so I was throwing her I
literally wrote in my notebook the first
day that she told sounds like I want to
write about being black and Thousand
Oaks like I think it's a good topic so I
got my group we had questions and I was
very thorough because I was like this
means something to me I'm gonna take
this very seriously so I interviewed the
youngest person I interviewed at the
time was my niece and she was eight and
the oldest person I interviewed was one
of my aunts and she was in her 50s and
so I had different skin tones I had
people that have lived in Thousand Oaks
their whole life or his people that come
from other places versus boys and girls
and all kinds of different stuff because
I really wanted to get the full gamut of
what it's like and I presented my
project by teachers and tears it was
great and I'm like sitting here and I'm
she's like you weren't in the
documentary what are your feelings I
said it's horrible having to represent
my entire race at every second of every
hour of every day and being a teen like
I've been doing this since I was five
like I always have to be on my P's and
Q's and I had boys in the back of my
class like laughing and I heard them
whisper like she's so dramatic oh my
gosh this is this is crap and they're
like laughing because they think it's
funny I'm like oh so my genuine
experiences are funny to you because in
your world I'm dramatic or loud and I'm
noisy and I'm obnoxious and I can't be
loud I'm taking up too much space and I
can't be loud because I'm an extrovert I
have to be loud because I'm black I
can't like certain music cuz I like the
way it sounds act like it cuz it's a
black artist or I can't identify with
people that look like me because then
I'm reverse racist it was Dave tried
everything in the book and I was like
okay
got it I'm sorry let me let me be quiet
so the the argument that racism will die
with a certain generation cheese age in
Z that is absolute bullshit the idea is
still being a lot of people are like
getting better it's getting quieter oh
shit it's getting quieter and more
underhanded it is it's getting quiet
it's getting quieter they're taking
posted this the racism isn't getting
worse it's just getting filmed huh
mm-hmm and it took people seeing black
pain and black death and us being
traumatized by going on I accidentally
saw what happened to a Ahmad Aubry cuz
I'm like what is this what same it was
on my my timeline and I clicked on and I
was like what is going on like what is
this truck doing like you know and in my
mind when I saw them fighting i I
couldn't now at this point I couldn't
stop watching and then I just see him
get shot and you know what the worst
part is I thought that the man that was
recording it was recording it in defense
of Ahmad Aubry but he was an accessory
he got in his car and blocked him in so
he was also charged so like I even to
think that that was you know what I'm
saying like we'd owe at least somebody
you know went and we know you recorded
that shit for sport not protection hmm
so that idea that it's getting better
with time that there's progress there is
no progress until it is recognized by
our president there is no progress and
tools recognized by our leaders in
government or to the same sentiment the
fact that we discount people's ages yeah
we discount like the little girl there
girl that was talking our parents off Oh
you're young you don't know anything I
hate that we feel as though whether
you're a young black person or a young
white person or whoever I feel like a
lot of times whatever they're saying
it's discounted because of their age oh
you don't know what you're talking about
you clear like like you guys said Oh
racism is gonna die out when all the old
people or die out like you learned that
yeah
can I ask you what are some shows that
you feel like capture the black
experience an authentic truthful way
that people who watch oh I always tell
people I love a different world
it's old it's old and I'm an old soul
but I feel as though I literally was
having an argument the other day about
this I feel as though it explains the
full gamut at least maybe cause it's my
age group but the full gamut of what
it's like to have to have be an educated
black person because we're not all just
thugs we're not all out like for the
most part we're not we're just out here
trying to live our lives so having to
even in a black college setting
experience racism I feels great I also
personally love blackish and groaning I
feel like they touch on a lot of stuff
and they do it in a way that's palatable
so it's not directly in your face but
like a lot of because Zoey and I are
supposed to be the same age a lot of
what Zoe's gone through I have gone
through it I personally have gone
through exactly what Amber was saying
because I speak properly or eloquently
I've had teachers look at me twice and
be like oh this this one's different I
hate that sentence this one's different
the amount of times I've heard that it's
any earth the first time I the teacher
said it's me I was in third grade I'm
eight and to hear a teacher go oh you're
different
this one this one so automatically the
entire rest of my race is bad but me I'm
fine cuz I grew up around white people
whoa I'm texting your mom right now
right now I can't even I can't even talk
yo like if you ever need a gin Z
corresponding
this is it right here this is it but
also like yeah I think it's just
important to know your limitations and I
don't love admitting I have limitations
but like it's just you know some things
that I don't know how I can understand
unless we give you the microphone unless
we you make a documentary unless you
make a TV show and you know and yes sort
of like you can't stop and educate every
person you don't have that kind of time
you know so we just need to figure out a
way to like and I've liked this is
making steps and like we appreciate it
cuz it's like some of us have voices and
we know what we want to say but we don't
know exactly how to say them or if it's
right for us to say them because like I
said people discount because of your age
or because of what you've experienced or
where you've grown up so it's like where
am I supposed to say what I have to say
or like where do I fit in into the
puzzle because you see the Amber's and
the people and the Kendricks that are
out here they're like okay I see that
but that's not my path like how do I
figure out where I fit into the whole
hodgepodge I think your point is right
like I even have had to learn like I
can't educate everyone because my stance
has always been my my thought process
has always been I was fortunate enough
to be put around people that instilled
in me from a very young age your voice
matters
and you have a responsibility and they
always taught me not everybody's bad
some people are just uneducated thank
you which is the thing that I always
tried to I always try to come out from
like cuz like amber I was almost a
teacher so I taught fifth and sixth
grade so I get not everybody it doesn't
click for everybody all at the same time
so like for me there's people who are
like why are you still talking and then
why are you trying to help them you've
been talking in for four days now and
I'm like okay but I think I'm almost
getting to the clicking point but I also
realized like I can't I can't run it to
the power I'm low and now because I've
spent so much time trying to explain it
to you the next person that asked me I'm
gonna snap on them because I'm tired
that's right oh well I could I could I
can't ask you for any more thank you for
inviting me I really appreciate you like
personally reaching out to me that meant
a lot it was I was so nervous to reach
out to you because I was just like I do
not want to fucking make her do what
she's doing enough you know yeah yeah
they do yeah I just want to talk about a
mutiny again and just encourage you know
every single black creative in the
entertainment space to use that hashtag
on Twitter or Instagram to tell their
stories because we are collecting them
and doing something really great that
you're going to appreciate with them and
yeah my if you want to Instagram me it's
at ms/ms amber P Riley and the same for
my Twitter and yeah that's it I just I
love being here and thank you for having
me of course thank you
listen it's okay
[Music]
[Applause]
you